Brian Kilmeade.com FOR HOW TO
GET TICKETS.
THE WAR ON HISTORY AND HOW TO
WIN IT.
♪ ♪
>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY,"
BUSY BREAKING NEWS NIGHT.
DISTURBING NEWS FROM
AFGHANISTAN.
FOUR DANGEROUS GET MY DETAINEES
RELEASED BY OBAMA AND BIDEN IN
2014.
THEY HAVE NOW BEEN APPOINTED TO
KEY POSITIONS IN THE NEW ISLAMIC
EMIRATE KNOWN AS AFGHANISTAN.
GREAT JOB, JOE AND BARACK.
THEY JOINED SEVERAL OTHER
NOTABLE TERRORISTS AT THE TOP OF
THE TALIBAN'S NEW GOVERNMENT.
THESE RADICAL ISLAMISTS ARE
HOLDING OUR FELLOW AMERICANS
HOSTAGE, BLOCKING THEM FROM
LEAVING THE COUNTRY, HUNTING FOR
ANYONE THAT HELPED AMERICA THAT
HAS WESTERN TIES IN THE LAST 20
YEARS, BUT TONIGHT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION ARE MORE
CONCERNED WITH THE TALIBAN'S
LACK OF INCLUSIVITY.
I WISH I WAS KIDDING BUT I AM
NOT.
DAY 25, AMERICANS HELD HOSTAGE.
>> WITH REGARD TO THE
COMPOSITION OF THIS GOVERNMENT
OR INTERIM GOVERNMENT, IT
INCLUDES PEOPLE WHO HAVE VERY
CHALLENGING TRACK RECORDS.
>> ALLOWING THE TALIBAN TO PICK
ITS MOST WANTED, IT'S TOP DRAFT
PICKS OUT OF GUANTANAMO, TO SEE
THEM IN CHARGE OF WHAT IS
QUICKLY BECOMING A TERRORIST
SUPERSTATE IS JUST A SLAP IN THE
FACE.
>> SO I GUESS WE SHOULDN'T BE
SURPRISED WHEN TERRORISTS,
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN LET GO AND
EVERYTHING ELSE ARE RUNNING THE
VERY ORGANIZATION THAT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT AND
ADMINISTRATION IS TRYING TO
NEGOTIATE.
IT MAKES ABSOLUTELY NO SENSE.
>> EVERY TIME I DON'T THINK THE
SITUATION COULD GET WORSE, IT
DOES.
>> AMERICANS HELD HOSTAGE BEHIND
ENEMY LINES, DAY 25.
>> Sean: ABANDONED BEHIND
ENEMY LINES.
LET ME SAY THIS ONE MORE TIME.
ALL OF THIS COULD HAVE BEEN
PREVENTED EASILY, FROM APRIL TO
MAY, FROM MAY TO JUNE TO JULY TO
AUGUST, WE HAD MONTHS TO
WITHDRAW ALL OF OUR PEOPLE.
WE HAD A DUTY, WE SAW THE
TALIBAN ADVANCING, WE COULD HAVE
EASILY MAINTAINED CONTROL OF THE
AIR BASE, WE COULD HAVE
AGGRESSIVELY BOMBED THE TALIBAN
WITH DRONES AND WE COULD HAVE
EXPEDITED THE WITHDRAWAL OF
AMERICANS AND THEIR FAMILIES AND
ALSO OUR AFGHAN ALLIES AND THE
BILLION DOLLARS PLUS, BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS WORTH OF MILITARY
EQUIPMENT WHILE WE HAD FULL
CONTROL.
BIDEN WAS WARNED DAILY BY THE
INTEL COMMUNITY ABOUT THE
DETERIORATING SITUATION.
HE CHOSE TO LIVE TO THIS
COUNTRY, LIED TO ALL OF US ABOUT
THE WELL-TRAINED AFGHAN
MILITARY.
THEY WERE ALL GETTING THEIR ASSS
CAKES WHILE THE ENTIRE WORLD
WATCHED AND LYING TO THE WORLD.
NOW THE FATE OF OUR FELLOW
AMERICANS RESTS IN THE HANDS OF
TERRORISTS INCLUDING ISLAMISTS
ONCE IN PRISON AT GUANTANAMO BAY
FREE IN EXCHANGE FOR A FORMER
ARMY DESERTER BY BIDEN AND
OBAMA.
IN 2015 DURING HIS ANNOUNCEMENT
SPEECH THEN CANDIDATE TRUMP
PREDICTED THAT THIS BERGDAHL
TALIBAN PRISON SWAP, HE
PREDICTED IT WOULD END IN
DISASTER.
OSAMA BIN LADEN, A BAD GUY, THAT
WAS NOT GOING TO END WELL.
TAKE A LOOK.
TO SPEAK OF THE PEOPLE DON'T
HAVE A CLUE.
OUR PRESIDENT DOESN'T HAVE A
CLUE, HE IS A BAD NEGOTIATOR.
HE IS THE ONE THAT DID BERGDAHL.
THEY GET BERGDAHL, THEY GET FIVE
KILLER TERRORISTS THAT
EVERYBODY WANTED OVER THERE, WE
GET BERGDAHL, WE GET A NO GOOD
TRADER AND THEY GET THE FIVE
PEOPLE THEY WANTED FOR YEARS AND
THEY ARE NOW BACK ON THE
BATTLEFIELD TRYING TO KILL US.
>> Sean: DONALD TRUMP WAS
RIGHT, TWO YEARS LATER
BOWE BERGDAHL PLEADED GUILTY TO
DESERTION AND MISBEHAVIOR BEFORE
THE ENEMY AND NOW FOUR OUT OF
THE FIVE DETAINEES, THEY ARE IN
LEADERSHIP POSITIONS NOW ATOP
THE NEW GOVERNMENT WHICH WILL
SWEAR THEMSELVES AND I BELIEVE
ON THE 20TH ANNIVERSARY OF
SEPTEMBER 11TH 2001.
AND AS WE FIRST REPORTED LAST
NIGHT, THESE TERRORISTS ARE
BLOCKING PRIVATE CHARTER FLIGHTS
FROM EXTRACTING OUR OWN AMERICAN
CITIZENS AND ACCORDING TO
BIDEN'S OWN SECRETARY OF STATE,
ANTONY BLINKEN, OUR ABILITY TO
GET THOSE PLANES IN THE SKY IS
PRETTY LIMITED WITHOUT THE
CONTROL OF AN AIRPORT OR BOOTS
ON THE GROUND.
WATCH THIS.
>> AS OF NOW, THE TALIBAN ARE
NOT COMMITTING THE CHARTER
FLIGHTS TO DEPART.
THEY CLAIMED THAT SOME OF THE
PASSENGERS DO NOT HAVE THE
REQUIRED DOCUMENTATION.
WHILE THERE ARE LIMITS TO WHAT
WE CAN DO WITHOUT PERSONNEL ON
THE GROUND, WITHOUT AN AIRPORT
WITH NORMAL SECURITY PROCEDURES
IN PLACE, WE ARE WORKING TO DO
EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER TO
SUPPORT THOSE FLIGHTS AND TO GET
THEM OFF THE GROUND.
>> Sean: AND THE
STATE DEPARTMENT SAID THAT EVEN
IF THOSE PRIVATE CHARTER PLANES
GET PERMISSION TO LAND IN A
COUNTRY, THEY CAN'T COME TO THE
U.S., THAT IS NOT AN OPTION.
HOW WAS THAT POSSIBLE WHEN WE
HAVE U.S. CITIZENS ON BOARD?
BUT IF THEY GET PERMISSION BUT
THAT PERMISSION IS PREDICATED ON
PERMISSION FROM OUR
STATE DEPARTMENT, THE ANSWER
WILL BE NO.
EXPLAIN THAT TO ME.
BIDEN SAID WE HAD ALL THE
LEVERAGE?
WHERE IS THE LEVERAGE, JOE?
IF ONLY WE HELD OUT OR KEPT
FORCES ON THE GROUND, OR USED
PREDATOR DRONES TO PUSH BACK THE
TALIBAN OR SPEEDING UP THE
WITHDRAWAL UNTIL EVERY AMERICAN
WAS OUT, EVERY AFGHAN ALLY WAS
OUT, ALL OUR MILITARY EQUIPMENT
WAS OUT, NONE OF THAT HAPPENED
AND YOU HAD MONTHS WATCHING THIS
UNFOLD.
NOW BLINKEN SEEMS LESS CONCERNED
WITH THE AMERICANS LEFT BEHIND.
HE'S MORE CONCERNED WITH THE
LACK OF DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION
IN THE TALIBAN'S NEW GOVERNMENT.
WHEN THE TALIBAN WAS IN POWER
THE LAST TIME, GIRLS COULDN'T GO
TO SCHOOL, WOMEN COULDN'T GO TO
WORK, THEY WERE SUBJUGATED TO
MEN.
YOUNG GIRLS WERE TAKEN AS EX-AND
WIVES
TO THE TALIBAN FIGHTERS.
DO YOU THINK WE HAVE
CHANGED?
I DOUBT IT'S.
>> YESTERDAY THE TALIBAN NAMED A
NEW INTERIM GOVERNMENT.
DESPITE THINKING THAT THE NEW
GOVERNMENT WOULD BE INCLUSIVE IT
INCLUDES NO WOMEN.
IT CERTAINLY DOES NOT MEET THE
TEST OF INCLUSIVITY AND IT
INCLUDES PEOPLE WHO HAVE VERY
CHALLENGING TRACK RECORDS.
>> Sean: A STUNNING LACK OF
INCLUSIVITY FROM A TERRORIST
ORGANIZATION THAT WE ALREADY
KNOW ENSLAVES WOMEN, SUBJUGATES
WOMEN AND FORCES YOUNG GIRLS
AGAINST THEIR WILL TO MARRY
TALIBAN FIGHTERS AND THEY MURDER
MUSICIANS AND ARTISTS AND
ANYBODY THEY DON'T LIKE.
THAT MAKES SENSE?
HE IS A TERRORIST, MR. BLINKEN.
HOW STUPID ARE YOU?
THEY ARE WHIPPING WOMEN AND
CHILDREN WITH WIRES AT THE
AIRPORT.
THEY ARE HUNTING DOWN FEMALE
AFGHAN POLICE OFFICERS AND
MURDERING THEM RIGHT IN THE
STREET.
YOU SEE THE REPORTS, YOU KNOW
THE TRUTH.
THEY HELPED PLAN THE 9/11
TERRORIST ATTACKS THAT TOOK OUT
NEARLY 3,000 AMERICANS.
2,977 IF MY MEMORY SERVES ME
CORRECTLY.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
WORRIED OVER THE LACK OF GENDER
DIVERSITY IN THE TALIBAN'S NEW
GOVERNMENT.
ARE YOU REALLY THAT IGNORANT?
SADLY, IT APPEARS THE ANSWER IS
YES.
A BAD
BRAND-NEW AD FROM TRUMP SAVEAMEE
LEVEL OF INCOMPETENCE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> HOW DID PRESIDENT BIDEN GET
THIS ALL WRONG?
>> THEY CLEARLY HAD THE CAPACITY
TO SUSTAIN THE GOVERNMENT IN
PLACE.
>> THIS HAS BEEN A DISASTER.
SPEAK AT THE TALIBAN IS NOT THE
NORTH VIETNAMESE ARMY.
>> LOOKS LIKE SAIGON 2.0 TO ME.
SPEAK OF THE LIKELIHOOD AS THE
TALIBAN OVERRUNNING EVERYTHING
AND OWNING THE WHOLE COUNTRY IS
HIGHLY UNLIKELY.
>> THIS TRAGEDY WAS COMPLETELY
PREVENTABLE.
>> WE TOLD YOU JOE BIDEN WAS NOT
UP TO THE JOB.
NOW WE ARE SEEING THE
DEVASTATING CONSEQUENCES OF HIS
INCOMPETENCE.
BIDEN VACATIONED WHILE
AFGHANISTAN COLLAPSED.
AMERICAN MILITARY EQUIPMENT WAS
PLUNDERED AND NOW AMERICA WEEPS
OVER THE SACRIFICE DUE TO
BIDEN'S SURRENDER.
>> Sean: JOE BIDEN WAS STILL
TELLING US ONE OF THE BEST
TRAINED ARMIES IN THE WORLD, ONE
OF THE BEST TRAINED MILITARIES
IN THE WORLD AFTER THE TALIBAN
HAD THE AFGHAN MILITARY ARMY IN
FULL COLLAPSE AND HAD TAKEN OVER
60% OF THE COUNTRY.
HOW DO YOU GET IT THAT WRONG
WHEN YOU KNOW IT'S WRONG?
MAYBE THAT IS SOMETHING TO DO
WITH HIS STEEP COGNITIVE
DECLINE.
JOE BIDEN SEEMS TO HAVE A HARD
TIME SPEAKING, THINKING, WALKING
AND DOING ANY BASIC FUNCTION AT
THIS POINT FOR HIMSELF, SO HIS
STAFF OF SOCIAL JUSTICE
WARRIORS, THEY SEEM TO BE
CALLING THE SHOTS BUT DON'T TAKE
MY WORD FOR IT.
JUST LOOK AT THIS OTHER STRANGE
MOMENT FROM BIDEN EARLIER TODAY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> NOW I'M SUPPOSED TO STOP AND
WALK OUT OF THE ROOM HERE.
[LAUGHTER]
I'M GOING TO STOP IN WITH YOUR
PERMISSION I'M GOING TO WALK
INTO THE ROOM.
THANK YOU.
>> Sean: I KNOW WE DON'T CALL
THEM TORNADOES ANYMORE EITHER.
IT STOPPED BEING FUNNY A LONG
TIME AGO.
HUNDREDS OF AMERICANS ARE HELD
HOSTAGE, 13 BRAVE AMERICAN
HEROES ARE DEAD BECAUSE OF THAT
GUY'S INCOMPETENCE.
ONE GOLD STAR MOTHER INVITED
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP TO HER
SON'S FUNERAL, NOT JOE BIDEN.
ALL THESE 9/11 FAMILIES SAYING,
DON'T COME TO OUR MEMORIALS ON
9/11.
AND THIS MOTHER SAYS THAT
JOE BIDEN HAS BLOOD ON HIS
HANDS.
IN A SOCIAL MEDIA POST SHE
CALLED BIDEN A WEAK HUMAN BEING
AND A TRAITOR.
JOE BIDEN TRULY IS A WEAK HUMAN
BEING IN EVERY WAY, PHYSICALLY,
MENTALLY, MORALLY AND NOW A VAST
MAJORITY OF AMERICANS SEEM TO
AGREE.
A NEW DEMOCRATIC LEANING YOU
LEANING YUGO OF ECONOMIST POLL
SHOW